わかるもう治りかけなんですけどここ2つマメができてますこれ何でできたかというと
釣りのゲームあるじゃないですかのゲーセンであのメダル入れてちょっとラ行15枚
使ったらいいロッドが使えるみたいなそのなんか次のゲームでボスのめちゃくちゃ
でかい黄色の魚がいたんですよそれでめちゃくちゃ釣りに吹いらしいんですけど僕一発
で連れてもうねぇ
yeah
めっちゃ回してずれてるっちゃメダル100枚くらい来たんですけどもこれを異常な力
すぎて指のマメが2つ潰れて違う止まりませんでした
んコンビニってすごい量の組ありませんかあなたにはここにあればそれですは僕がまだ
赤子だった時は3つか4つくらいだった気がするぜバグって売れるのかな塗りてるか
信頼んですけど気づいたらもうすごい量の組が販売されててやばいちょ種類がくみくみ
の種類が多くて着れば気づいたらこれだけの量の組のコンビニで売ってましたこれ
じゃあ本命に入ってタグに全種類
ですたいで今回は素朴な疑問足を過ぎないですか
コンビニの愚民の種類が多すぎてどれを食べていいかわからないそんな時が僕ために
あるんですけどもそれぞれいろんな具ミナージュが立つということはみなさんおいしい
首を作ろうと努力しているわけでございますこの凄い凄い競争社会4組アイドルの戦国
時代のために今組の戦国時代が来てるわけですよ組を意識で売れる
からおいしい米を出せば売れるんじゃないからもっといろんな会社がたくさんだけで
作ってるわけでしょ今ソースて気づいたらホビーでこんなたくさんの種類の国が販売さ
れていた弦等ございますなぁねやっぱり皆さん目指すところは一つなるんで美味しい
グミを作ることただ一つということは今家の前ひとまとまりにして一つの組にしたそれ
はいつもおいしいんじゃないか要するにみんなあるでしょ
ね皆さん目指してるとこ
を一緒でしょ
ほらね1な人皆さんおいしい文を作りたいその一心でいろんな会社の方はがんばって
いるんでそれでんなパドルで一つの組にしたらそれがた
至極史上最強の一緒に組なんじゃないかという結論に至ったので今回これ全部混ぜね
ひとつの首をつけていこうと思いますねー
色よっしゃっていくぞよピュレグミ入れドリーム中にいますかったサマー組のラムネ
噛み応えが強すぎて開きましたグレープ基本的に全部食べたもあるの
恋空4戦でやるけど43ですよフィットチーネ組のレモンやビーチじゃあそういう高れ
もう組のゴールで恋あり僕にグレープフルーツ
一美 kazumi 中国道
ワウあり番組コーラ芸弾力桁違いだったな
フィットチーネグレー部か2部に美味しく鉄分
すげーなーちょっと健康志向かかじるたび恋しくコラーゲハニー napa
ちょっとってすげー中からだ兄組ができる気がしてきたぞ避ける組はすっごいなんか
これはすごいなゴッチ中でぴゃー組ピッチこれすげー
柔らかいのペロリームリンガーヘルシーでスナッキングもわかんないコーナー
うわああああああトっぽい今のに守備からビス組2種類こいつは全く読めねーなー
果たしてどんな味になるのでしょうか
快適でグリーンが対する出揃いましたもうバラバラはナタクまとまりのない組たち
みんなバラバラってことはやっぱりいろんな楽しみ方があるわけじゃないんですか組を
柔らかくてこの果汁があふれる
海もあれば神舞台が固いハードな組健康志向の組もあれば鉄分が摂れる首は本当に組
ってだけでいろんな種類の味わい方がある奴を俺がならちょっとにまとめてやる
[音楽]
anitta pl
昨日ハンズは疑問人は家族に聞いたからにきついしてねうううううえええ
これはまだ1かたまにするんですけど熱を使います
ってちょっと溶けてる間に頑張ってみんなひとつになろうそうそそうそういうそうそう
いうのはそう言うなよ
こーゆーかでちょっと舌とかっていきましょう
[音楽]
大きいのではないでしょうか適量の大きさにして冷蔵庫で冷やしてちゃんとクリーム
などを待ちますでは入んないんだけど
う脱ぐなそうそのまま落ちても税の
だーっ同然だこれやばいじゃあもう ad 4 p プレイたーーーーも軟調なに2つ
は本当に組7述べるのが得意なフレーズなんだねすごい書士
ちょっとぞアンダーズあるよじゃあさっそく冷やしていきます
[音楽]
何があっあいうジェットマン固まったんですけども意味が分からないあなたに感謝何が
どうなっている例えばこれでひとまず全部の組が合体してラジなるので美味しいな
間違いないと思い早速食べてみたいと思いますいただきます
[音楽]
覇を唱え具合4 a
ああああああ
うーん
ええええええ
ああはい中だ
[音楽]
me
uh
うううう
me
uh